il est rare que des magistrats acceptent
de rouvrir un dossier jugé concernant un
crime et pourtant la commission de
révision de la cour de cassation vient
d'ordonner un supplément d'enquêté sur
un double meurtre commis en 1986 en
lorraine pour ce double meurtre
un garçon âgé de 16 ans a été condamné à
la réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
il semblerait que ce soit francis
heaulme ce tueur en série déjà condamné
pour deux meurtres est poursuivi pour
une dizaine d'autres qui soit le vrai
coupable
commentaire de me garder y en
casqués et protégés escorté patrick dils
apparaît lors de la reconstitution 86
comme le coupable idéal
après 36 heures de garde à vue il avoue
le double meurtre d'alexandre et de
cyril puis il se rétracte les deux
jeunes garçons ont été massacrés à coups
de pierres en septembre 86 le long d'une
voie ferrée
trois ans plus tard la cour d'assises de
metz fait de patrick dils âgé alors de
18 ans le plus jeune condamné à
perpétuité de france depuis bientôt dix
ans ses parents s'élèvent contre cette
condamnation sans preuve on a cherché un
coupable parce qu'il fallait comme
calmer l'opinion publique et à ce moment
là il ya aussi beaucoup de meurtres
d'enfants
alors on attend besson patrick
aujourd'hui la commission de révision de
la cour de cassation décide de rouvrir
le dossier
la justice dispose d'un nouveau suspect
et ce n'est pas un inconnu
francis heaulme a déjà été condamné
trois fois et mises en examen dans neuf
dossiers il n'a pas avoué le double
assassinat mais il reconnaît avoir été
sur les lieux du crime en septembre 86
pour l'avocat de patrick dils
cela suffirait à innocenter son client
l'aveu que ce garçon a passé alors qu'il
était mineur au moment des faits et au
moment de sa garde à vue n'est pas un
aveu convaincant d'abord parce qu'il a
été donnée par une personne extrêmement
fragile et vulnérable d'après les
experts l'avocat des parties civiles lui
parle d' aveux crédible je crois qu'on
peut pas on ne peut pas imaginer qu'on
ait pu avoir inventé ça ou qu'il ya eu
des détails qu'ils aient pu être
inventées ou données ou imaginé cette
info chine franchement c'est abusé
la justice s'est elle trompée de
coupable aux magistrats de la cour de
cassation de répondre patrick dils lui
est en prison depuis 12 ans